surveillance in moscow was the most
difficult kind of surveillance that we
encountered around the world
we didn't have paris rules or buenos
aires rules
there were no other rules except moscow
rules
because it was such a difficult place
for us to work
hi i'm johna mendez i'm the former chief
of disguise for the cia
today i'm going to talk about some of
the cia's gadgets that we use during the
cold war
i worked for the office of technical
service at the cia
we used to always think of it as cia's
cue we were the gadget people
everything that we did in moscow had to
be done
clandestinely you couldn't overtly go
out and collect intelligence
we all had surveillance 24 hours a day
seven days a week it didn't matter where
you were
if you were in your apartment which
would be in an embassy compound
you'd have surveillance in the walls and
it would be live surveillance
we had something of a breakthrough in uh
determining whether or not we had
surveillance and that was
a piece of equipment that we called the
srr 100 it was actually composed of
three different pieces one was some
small phonak
ear devices that went into your ear they
were ear pieces
and they were actually commercially
available but we would
mold your ear and create a new inner
ear for you that would sit in on top of
the phonak
we would paint them to match your ear
there was a neck ring that went with it
it was an induction piece of technology
and then there was
a receiver itself those were tuned into
kgb surveillance frequencies and we had
a fairly comfortable sense
that if we had surveillance following us
they were using radios we were on their
frequency
that we would be able to hear them that
we would be able to correlate
if we turned right or if we turned left
that we would hear them calling that out
he's turning right he's turning left
it wasn't foolproof but it was enough to
give us
a very good sense of if there was
anybody back there
knowing that you were being watched
would mean that that day
all you would do is perfectly innocuous
things
you would not do anything operational
that day because you were under
surveillance
another method of losing surveillance
was using one of our sams one of our
semi-animated masks
it was a mask that would allow you to
apply different disguise materials all
at one time
which would allow you to get in the car
wherever you were
wearing your true face and somewhere
along the way
putting on your new face your sam mask
and after you'd taken two right-hand
turns
and stepped out of the car when
surveillance came down the street
they would see what maybe looked like a
russian man walking
toward them and the car they were
following still
up ahead of them they would go right by
you so that if you were a blonde
unshaven unmustached young man
and needed to wear a disguise that night
that might have a dark beard
dark mustache dark hair maybe a
different skin tone
instead of having to sit in front of a
mirror and assemble
that on your face you would just take
your
sam mask and so it had a nickname
the five second mask five on five off
but there was one last piece it had to
crumble down to almost nothing and fit
under your armpit
if you were being pursued and you had to
take it off
and had to turn into your real self you
had to be able to conceal it
another technique that we used with the
masks was
an operation called line doggo we had a
couple
getting ready to go to moscow and we
asked them to buy a dog
and take the dog with them a very large
dog a particular dog
we went to our wick maker we showed the
wig maker a picture of the great big dog
and she made not a wig but she made a
dog
just a covering that looked like a dog
that you could put in the back seat of a
car
and it would look like your dog was
asleep in the back seat
that couple would set a pattern
of every i don't know how often but
every so often
they would leave the embassy compound
with their dog
and so the man at the gate would get
used to seeing them go through the gate
with their dog in the back seat not
always asleep
sometimes asleep and then when we needed
operationally
to move a person that person would get
in the car
under the dog concealment and go through
the gate
and the milly man would blink twice and
that was a way to move
a person around we had a device called
the jack in the box
or a jib when we use the jib a dummy
would
pop up out of a concealment device
replacing the officer
who had just stepped out of the car and
so the way it would typically work is
the driver would get in the car
the passenger which would be the case
officer who needed to get
out of the car and go do his operational
stuff
he'd be in the passenger seat and so
they'd go out through the gate
and their surveillance team would pull
in behind them and they'd go
on a pre-determined route one that they
had planned
specifically to do a car escape they
would find a right turn
followed by another right turn they
would have disconnected their
brake lights the officer would open the
door
step out of the car the driver would
take
the purse the attache set it on the
passenger seat push the button thing
would pop
up surveillance comes around the corner
there's still two silhouettes in the car
moving down the street not too fast
and our officer would be free to go and
do
an operational act this was a very
important tool
and once an agent loses their
surveillance
and is absolutely certain that they have
lost their surveillance
they can do anything a dead drop is the
way we would
package the information that we were
giving to the agent
where we could put our questions for the
agent in
some sort of a concealment device and
put it on the ground somewhere
or in a tree or wherever the proper
place was determined to be
and they on the other hand could give us
the answers to our questions
by doing the same thing it could be a
list of requirements
we could be passing to him medicine for
his son who was sick
it could be money whatever we needed to
pass to the agent
had to be concealed so that it wasn't
apparent what it was
because we were going to put it down
somewhere and leave it
unattended and put up a signal so he'd
know to come and get it
a signal to an agent it's a prearranged
so the agent knows what to look for
it could be a lipstick mark on a
telephone pole it could be a light in a
window
it could be moving a flower pot on a
balcony from one side to another it was
an endless
supply of possibilities for signals the
dead drop that that
has gotten the most attention over the
years
is the dead rat we determined early on
that a dead rat was
pretty much untouchable in any country
in any religion by any people
no one will pick up a dead rat they just
won't so we did we picked up dead rats
and we took them to the taxidermist and
they tidied them up and they velcroed
their tummies
oh and they dipped them in tabasco sauce
the tabasco was in case
an animal picked up your dead rat you
could fit more in a dead rat than you
might
think if you were determined to get a
certain number of rubles
or a certain number of questions or
maybe some old antique jewelry
if you roll dollar bills up real tight
with rubber bands you can get a lot of
dollar bills in
or rubles i think i liked one that we
put down for trigon early on over rodnik
over rodnik was his soviet name trigon
was his code name
he was giving us information on the
strategic arms limitations talks
it's called the salt talks this was salt
too he was giving us a soviet bottom
line
on negotiating what they were willing to
do and below which they would not go
which is like if you're playing poker
it's like having
the other guy's cards in your hands and
we left i believe it was his first drop
and we left it
in in a dirty construction glove just
one
just on the ground by phone booth that
was the first thing he picked up from us
we devised many concealment devices in
ots and some of them were used for
escape scenarios
the false scrotum is a really
interesting
story we were always interested
in the possibility of our officers being
captured
and maybe being held prisoner around the
world our officers
needed to be able to hide
some tools so that they could make an
attempt to escape if that happened to
them
and the theory is that the false scrotum
was one
such concealment device the question
about the false scrotum
is whether it was ever actually used
if you were going to be in a situation
where you would be
strip searched you might in advance
knowing that you were going into a
life and death situation prepare
yourself like houdini to have some
escape tools
the rectal tool kit was a little bit
like a suppository
it just you put it in case you needed it
it was important that it be very well
made
that it be very smooth surface that it
not
caused any injury coming or going
but inside of it were small tools that
could be
used in a variety of ways it was not a
bad idea
so some of these agents that worked for
us knew that
there was not a good ending if it ended
and they said
will only work for you if you give us
cyanide pills
the first two that i know of we gave out
in pens in writing pens they were in the
cap of the pen
what we're looking at here is a cyanide
pill that was put
in the bow stem of a pair of glasses and
the way it was constructed
is that the agent in order to access the
pill would just
take off his glasses and just
[Music]
bite down on the earpiece there was a
glass ampoule inside with the cyanide in
it
it was a desperate measure but they were
desperate times and these men knew
that they didn't want to go through the
interrogation and the torture that the
kgb had in mind
before they were executed trigon was
arrested
at home in his office the kgb came in
they had found all of his tools all of
his supplies
he had nowhere to go and so
they had him stripped of his clothes he
just had on his skivvies
and he said to them i will write my
confession but i want to write it with
my pen
my pen he wanted his mom block pen and
they gave it to him
and my office ots had milled out the cap
so he he took the cap off and he
put it on top and he looked at them and
he just
bit down on it the russians said he was
dead before he hit the floor
i hope that's what he wanted
working in moscow really was a life and
death
operation all the time
you were risking the life of your agent
you made a mistake you were always
worried
if your equipment wasn't working if your
trade craft wasn't what it should be
whenever someone got caught you went
home and thought oh god
is it something that i did did i make
the mistake
while these devices were primarily used
during the cold war
some version of these devices is in use
today
the business of meeting with spies and
collecting intelligence and transmitting
the intelligence
those things don't change how we do it
might change
but it's still the same work
you